What's some words of advice
that you would give
like the new builder
or the new content creator
to kind of just
get started, get going?
I think the first thing
is be very real
with yourself what people want,
and don't be like,
oh, I like this, I
think it's gonna be cool.
But actually ask people
what they want and
then go deliver on that,
and then deliver on that
10x what people expect.
If they expect a
hundred word thing on Twitter,
go and write a
thousand word essay.
Essays were popping up
on Twitter, but
not many people
had the inertia.
They didn't do it
until they saw it
pop up and by
the time it pop up,
everyone's writing articles already.
So the first few
that actually wrote articles
did really well.
Find your niche,
listen to what people want,
and then just like go
in fast and triple
down on that.